do you see the beauty of it my Swift and
terrible sword and the earth will crack
with the weight of your failure when the
dust settles the only thing living in
this world will be metal in 2015 the
world reeled from attacks from enhanced
individuals it was not prepared for the
tragedy in sokovia under the leadership
of ultron a robot army descended on the
peaceful town of novigrad sokovia a
province known for its wheat production
and fine woollen goods in a battle that
pitted sibling against sibling the
otherwise sleepy town of Novi Grodd was
levitated into the sky hundreds of
thousands of sokovia pnes perished and
the world was forever changed but in the
wake of the tragedy countries around the
world rallied around a common cause in
response to the sokovia tragedy and the
super villain Ultron the world knew what
it needed to regulate enhanced
individuals
that is legally problematic
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer welcome back to laws broken
where an attorney destroys your favorite
childhood movies by showing you how
illegal everything is because everything
is illegal today we are talking about
these sokovia accords from Captain
America Civil War and the rest of the
Avengers movies we're going to pretend
that it is an actual binding legal
document and analyze it in far far too
much detail for better or worse in the
wake of the Ultron disaster countries
worldwide through the United Nations
signed the sokovia accords the sokovia
accords are a phone book sized set of
regulations aimed squarely at the
Avengers personally and the
organization's shield it seeks to limit
these so-called enhanced individuals
including registration components
monitoring components and imprisonment
components I'm using the version of the
sokovia accords found at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe fandom wiki which you
can find at the link below
importantly some of the provisions only
applies to signatories of these sokovia
accords while other provisions apply to
all enhanced individuals whether they
sign or not this is quite the
constitutional problem so because this
is obviously the most important legal
analysis that I could possibly be doing
right now I put together 10 reasons why
these sokovia accords raise
constitutional questions but first I
want to talk about the legal landscape
in general specifically whether the
sokovia accords would even be US law and
number two what would the legal
framework be for dealing with enhanced
individuals in the absence of the
sokovia accords so first let's talk
about the Accords in general an accord
is not a US law I assume what the Marvel
writers meant here is that the sokovia
accords are an international treaty that
the US has signed but just because 177
countries sign an agreement doesn't
actually make it law in the United
States in the case of a treaty the
Senate has to approve the treaty by a
two-thirds vote under article 2 section
2 of the Constitution and there are tons
of examples of treaties that the US has
signed but not actually ratified that
includes the International Criminal
Court treaty the comprehensive
nuclear-test-ban
treaty the Kyoto Protocol and the Treaty
of Versailles basically the u.s. is
still in World War one but for the sake
of argument let's assume that the US
Senate has in fact ratified the sokovia
accords it's more fun that way in any
event even when treaties are ratified
they cannot violate the US Constitution
and in fact this was an issue when the
u.s. adopted NATO because it was thought
that the mutual defense treaty would
violate Congress's right to declare war
but before we get to analyzing the
actual sokovia accords themselves we
have to examine the status quo ex ante
of US criminal law and tort law Captain
America shaves at the restrictions of
the sokovia accords but it's not like in
the absence of the Accords he'd be
allowed to operate domestically in the
United States vigilantes are illegal as
we discussed in the video on the dark
night and all the laws that Batman broke
you can't just go around getting into
fights even for a good cause the
justification of self-defense
generally doesn't apply when you
intentionally put yourself in harm's way
and all of these enhanced individuals
are using deadly force which almost
always carries with it a duty to retreat
if you are able to do so of course US
law doesn't necessarily apply to the
Avengers actions in sokovia and other
foreign countries but the fact of the
matter is they are often operating
domestically where US law does apply
don't even get me started about issues
of federalism because even if enhanced
individuals were allowed under the
sokovia chords on the federal level
there's still all the state laws that
prohibit their actions and there's no
way federal law would preempt
garden-variety state laws about criminal
conduct now you might argue that it
seems like the Avengers and shield are
operating as an arm of the government
essentially like mercenaries which might
have given them legal cover under the
Battle of New York but if that's so that
they're operating as an arm of the US
government that carries with it all
kinds of constitutional protections and
that doesn't get them out of trouble by
the way Tony Stark created Ultron and
effectively Ultron is his product
entered into the stream of Commerce so
Tony Stark is probably personally liable
on a products liability or negligence
theory for all the damage that Ultron
did and since this is a Marvel movie I
put in after credits bonus scene about
that topic at the end of this video but
the fact that the writer has even
considered any of these legal issues is
why the adoption
of the sokovia accords is the best scene
in the MCU actually the best scene in
the MCU is the after-party form age of
Ultron because of how effectively it
uses a light fun moment between the
Avengers to reveal important information
about the main characters while still
being a funny scene actually the best
scene in the MCU
is the I'm always angry scene from the
first Avengers because it's just so
iconic well actually I'd say that the
best scene in the MCU is the military
propaganda montage in the original
Captain America movie because no other
scene is so subversive over-the-top and
hilarious all
yeah this is my Court objections
overruled but let's ignore those issues
and let's talk about the ten biggest
problems with the US version of the
sokovia accords so in order of ascending
constitutional infirmity let's start
with the compelled speech portion of the
sokovia accords the sokovia accords
state and I quote any enhanced
individual who agreed to sign must
register with the United Nations and
provide biometric data such as
fingerprints and DNA samples those with
secret identities must reveal their
legal names and true identities to the
United Nations this is a classic
provision of compelled speech some of
which applies to signatories and some of
which does not apply to signatories but
forcing individuals to give up their
secret identities is the government
compelling you to make a certain kind of
speech I am Iron Man and if the First
Amendment has a problem with the
government restricting certain speech
you can imagine that it is doubly
problematic if it forces individuals to
make a certain kind of speech for
example in the Supreme Court case of
West Virginia school board versus
Barnette the Supreme Court said that a
school could not force students to stand
and salute the flag that was compelled
speech and in the same way that you
can't force individuals to stand up and
salute the flag you can't force people
to give up their secret identities and
provide biometric data and fingerprints
to the US government
number two forced registration sounds a
lot like internment the sokovia accords
requires all enhanced individuals to at
least register with the government
whether they are using their powers or
not which sounds a lot like the
internment of the Japanese in World War
two under executive order 9066 by
President Roosevelt that executive order
was tested at the Supreme Court level in
a court case called Korematsu and a
Supreme Court did not overrule the
executive order which in turn the
japanese Korematsu is still good law
that being said I doubt the Supreme
Court would rule the same way today
despite the fact that the ruling has
never been overturned but in any event
it seems like this is a clear violation
of the Fourth and Fifth Amendment
protections and requirement for due
process number three
monitoring of enhanced individuals this
seems like a clear Fourth Amendment
problem
the sokovia accords state and I quote
those with innate powers must also wear
tracking bracelets at all times
the problem is warrantless monitoring
without probable cause just because
someone is an enhanced individual would
be a clear Fourth Amendment violation a
violation of the right to privacy being
enhanced doesn't necessarily mean that
you have probable cause to monitor them
and it would be crazy to have a blanket
monitoring system that monitored
everyone in the United States without
probable cause so it's very good that
the US government has never had a
program like that to monitor people
without probable cause
the Maccoby accords also state that
those with innate powers must submit to
a power analysis which will categorize
their threat level and determine
potential health risks this feels like a
huge violation of the right to privacy
the government can't just go around
doing medical examinations of
individuals just because it feels like
it or because it's in the public
interest people have individual rights
specifically to protect them from this
kind of invasive testing and
additionally it would probably be a
violation of Tony Stark's intellectual
property even if he hasn't patented the
Ironman suit it would probably be a
trade secret and the compelled power
analysis would probably violate his IP
rights to the suit that he created it's
working we're safe America is secure you
want my property you can't have it
number four the second amendments
individual right to bear arms while this
is still a huge point of controversy in
recent Supreme Court precedent in the
District of Columbia versus Heller the
Supreme Court confirmed that the Second
Amendment does provide an individual
right to bear arms so what is the
threshold for Ironman Falcon and war
machine to be able to use their
inventions that they created effectively
the Iron Man suits or the Falcon
machinery are just arms that they have
created and certainly in some
circumstances you are allowed to an
individual right to bear those arms now
obviously individuals are not allowed to
have military hardware but the sokovia
accords
make it clear where the individual right
to bear arms starts and where the
exclusion of military technology kicks
in and how that would apply to the
individuals who are not innately
enhanced but have created an enhanced
suit for themselves I have successfully
privatized world peace so given the
makeup of the current Supreme Court and
the deference shown to the individual
right to bear arms under the Second
Amendment you can bet that the sokovia
accords probably run afoul of that right
under the Constitution as well number
five a violation of the freedom to
associate the sokovia accords apply to
all of the Avengers even those who are
not enhanced effectively preventing them
from being a member of this community or
group now the First Amendment is most
famous for the individual right to
freedom of speech but the lesser-known
right of the First Amendment is the
right to voluntarily associate and the
sokovia accords prevent individuals from
associating with the private
organization called the Avengers and the
private organization called shield just
because you are an enhanced individual
doesn't mean you lack First Amendment
rights to be a part of the group that
you want to participate in number six
violation of the freedom to travel the
sokovia accords state and I quote any
enhanced individuals who sign are
prohibited from taking action in any
country other than their own unless they
are first given clearance by either that
country's government or by a United
Nations subcommittee think of it this
way your school has rules right like you
can't draw on the walls well your daddy
went to Germany and drew on the walls
with Captain America and that was a
violation of article 16 paragraph 3 of
the sokovia accords now the defined term
taking action can be read very broadly
would that prohibit all of the Avengers
from setting foot in any particular
country without getting the United
Nations subcommittee to allow them to
travel and would it prevent them from
traveling domestically in the United
States if it does that's clearly a
violation of the privileges and
immunities Clause of the US Constitution
and not to mention the violation of
various international laws that allow
freedom of travel particularly between
the US and EU I think that this is a
poorly drafted statement and it shows
how important it is to define the terms
that you're dealing with because
otherwise people will read them broadly
when they're written broadly and it can
have unintended consequences which takes
me to problem number seven which is
vagueness there is a constitutional rule
that requires criminal laws to state
explicitly and definitively what conduct
is punishable criminal laws that violate
this requirement are said to be void on
vagueness grounds the vagueness doctrine
is based on the due process clauses of
the fifth and fourteenth amendments to
the Constitution and I think that
there's a big problem here in terms of
what the enhanced individuals are being
accused of vague terms like taking
action vague terms as in what
constitutes an enhanced individual
itself
all of these are vagueness issues that
are probably so vague as to run afoul of
the due process clauses in the
Constitution that's why I need lawyers
to draft these things not comic book
artists but I digress it takes me to
issue number eight which is imprisonment
the sokovia accords effectively treat
enhanced individuals who fail to comply
with his Co V Accords as enemy
combatants now it's one thing to send
enemy combatants that are imprisoned in
a foreign theater of war and send them
to Guantanamo but it's another thing
entirely to send US citizens who were
found in the United States to the
equivalent of Guantanamo on some
Helicarrier some way this is a clear due
process violation you can't just put
people inside of a Helicarrier with no
lawyer no arraignment and no bail
that's clearly a Sixth Amendment
violation to the right to counsel you're
not gonna put me in a prison
you're not gonna put any of us in a
prison and the other side of that coin
is problem number 9 which is forced
conscription into combat the sokovia
accords appear to force certain enhanced
individuals into fighting for the US
government in certain times of war
effectively the draft but it's another
thing entirely to seek out certain
individuals specifically and then force
them into combat on behalf of the
government this seems like a clear
violation of the 13th amendments
prohibition against involuntary
servitude you might recall that we
fought a real civil war to prevent
involuntary servitude and slavery and
forcing enhanced individuals to fight
for the government seems to run afoul of
those prohibitions which takes me to
problem number 10 and the biggest
constitutional violation the violation
against habeas corpus ABS corpus is
Latin for produced the body and the
sokovia accords state and I quote any
individuals who use their powers to
break the law including those who take
part in extra legal vigilante activities
or are otherwise deemed to be a threat
to the safety of the general public may
be detained indefinitely without trial
if an enhanced individual violates the
accords or obstructs the actions of
those enforcing the Accords they may
likewise be arrested and detained
indefinitely without trial you might see
where this is going but simply detaining
people indefinitely without trial is the
classic constitutional problem and in
fact just simply deeming someone a
threat before they have committed any
kind of offense is like a pre-crime
prohibition which again runs afoul of
the Constitution the writ of habeas
corpus requires a person in custody to
be brought before court provided a
lawyer if they can't afford one and to
be protected by the US Constitution we
fought the war of independence to have
the protections of the Constitution to
prevent things like indefinite
imprisonment for no reason whatsoever
this violates the Fourth Amendment which
protects people from arbitrary arrests
it violates a Fifth Amendment's
protection against being deprived of
life liberty or property without due
process and it violates the sixth
amendments right to cow
Sol and a trial there's actually very
few parts of the Constitution that this
part of the sokovia accords don't
actually violate and that's why the
lawyers are the real superheroes in the
Marvel Universe
so in thinking about this
Ultron vision problem a little bit more
Tony created vision vision is Tony's
property his chattel so legally speaking
vision is like Tony's dog